what's going on guys this is Rob and
most of they're almost anybody on my
channel knows of course who I am I mean
you know the guy that runs comics
explained if you happen to stumble
across this video as you're going
through the search videos on YouTube or
whatever the case may be one of the
things that a lot of people are really
talking about really they're not talking
about it as much anymore but it has been
a huge talking point is the issue of the
monetization like most youtubers I have
a YouTube contact now my contact mostly
you know most likely has hundreds of
other people that they work with and so
I'm you know I'm not exceedingly special
you know I don't have like one person
that works only with me you know it
doesn't really work that way uh and so
what I've done you know really when I
had a handful of videos that were
demonetized yesterday and what I did is
I sat down I was so mad now it's like
okay I need to calm down I need to relax
and I need to compose my thoughts and a
reasonably worded email one too you know
find some measure of catharsis so I can
work my anger out and - so that one I
can make my presence known and I'm sorry
make up make my case known and - so that
I can have like a clear and concise
statement of what the problem is and
three we can find a solution because
it's one thing to just rant and rave and
complain like Twitter is really good
about that Twitter is really really good
you know about saying that's a problem
and then having no solution to what that
problem is and I don't want to be
Twitter and so the resultant and I've
basically gone through and I've you know
written out this entire email that
actually has a solution to the D
monetization issue which I'm gonna read
this email to you guys now because I
think I can make my case better than
better than I can so you know to my
youtube contact my video on Hal Jordan
and the Green Lantern Corps has been
waiting approval for monetization for
about three hours following its recent D
monetization this comes off two videos
which had been demonetized the day
before one of which was a live
question-and-answer session and the
other was on the origin of Polaris the
daughter of magneto neither of these
videos contained any content that could
be considered questionable or non
advertiser friendly barring of course
the possibility that advertisers hate
comic books I've noticed that this is a
consistent trend on my channel and
across YouTube for reasons that are
given I can't I can never I can never
get to these things without messing up
for reasons that are never given by
YouTube except by pointing to
exceedingly vague Community Guidelines
the videos on my channel and others are
demonetised almost every week and the
and the appeals process
is initiated which on my channel has
been known to take anywhere between two
to three hours all the way up to 36 or
even 48 hours if a video is demonetised
on a Sunday or a holiday I was under the
impression that YouTube exists to
empower content creators but at the
moment YouTube seems to exist to empower
advertisers if average Heiser's are able
to promote their products on my videos
due to my willingness to enable
monetization wouldn't content creators
take precedent after all of what use is
the desire to advertise a product if no
one's willing to allow the product to be
a to be advertised on their videos
furthermore if the reason for such
lengthy if the reason for such a lengthy
appeals process is a byproduct of a lack
of manpower then why would you tube
implement an algorithm which is unable
to tell the difference between the
statements Hitler did nothing wrong and
Hitler did everything wrong and then
lack the means to ensure the algorithm
works as is supposed to is YouTube not
concerned about the impact D
monetization has on its content creators
or is the concern for impact limited to
channels that generate quote unquote
Logan Paul money I fear that while
YouTube does stand as the largest video
sharing platform on the planet youtube's
content monetization system combined
with its D monetization I'm sorry with
this demonstration of enforcing its
Community Guidelines unevenly clearly
demonstrates an attitude that while all
content creators are equal some are more
equal than others in addition to this
the ramp and B monetization based on
undefined rules followed up with remonda
cessation and YouTube's refusal to
compensate content creators for lost
income based on a badly designed
algorithm demonstrates at worst a
complete indifference to content
creators and at best complete negligence
to this end I've included a plan
designed to fix YouTube's existing
algorithmic problems regarding D
monetization so the first part YouTube's
advertisement problems and my solution
which is really kind of the overarching
theme that's really just kind of the
second part of it
if tube filters May 2017 article is to
be believed which you'll find a link
down in the description now their
content creators nor advertisers
previously how to say in which ads
appeared on creator channels instead ad
revenue was thrown into a pool of sorts
an ad distribution was based strictly on
whether or not a channel was eligible
for monetization in light of the ad
pocalypse
YouTube's implemented a system of sorts
for advert
as allowing them to determine which
videos they're as would appear on using
a categorization system which includes
things like videos without tragedy and
conflict topics that did not touch on
sensitive and social issues as well as
videos that did not include sensational
or shocking content while this was
enough to appease advertisers and return
them to the platform this saw a paradigm
shift and how content creators are
viewed as opposed to advertisers instead
of seeing content creators as one part
of a team helping YouTube remain the top
video sharing platform instead content
creators are now viewed as second to
advertisers if advertisers can receive
an option to determine which videos
their ads will appear next to why are
content creators not given the same
option instead of implementing an
algorithm that erroneously D monetize as
videos I propose that you to provide a
tiered system for monetization as
follows tier one advertisers who do not
under any circumstance want their brands
appearing next to videos involving
tragedy and conflict since sensitive
social issues sexually suggestive
content us a sensational and shocking
content or content with profanity and
rough language tier two advertisers who
are a little less selective and not as
stringent as the first year this would
likely see a continuation of the current
situation regarding Madhi monetization
and YouTube's a requirement of admitting
fault
when videos are romana ties largely due
to the fact that not all advertisers in
this category would select the same
topics on which videos their ads would
appear next to and then tier three
advertisers who don't care what their
product appears next to you one thing I
also kind of thought about here just a
second ago as I was reading about that I
would think the best way to implement
that would literally be in the
monetization option for video you can do
it by video I'm sorry by an individual
video you can even do it by you know by
channel if you want your whole channel
to fall under that whole category but
you select one of these three or select
all three you can select you know the
first two you can select the middle one
you know you can select you know tier 1
or tier 2 or two or three however is it
you want to do it but while this tiered
system would take some fine-tuning I
think this design is superior to the
current system used by YouTube as it
allows content creators to gain a better
idea of whether or not their videos will
be D monetized by allowing for control
over which brands advertise on their
channels then so in closing
while I do enjoy YouTube as a video
sharing platform the current state of
arbitrary D monetization based on vague
guidelines combined with YouTube's
preference of advertisers / content
creators shows an attitude that YouTube
believes content creators will always be
here as this is where the money is while
there may be truth to this thing while
there may be truth to this statement in
the president I would like to remind
YouTube that at one time both myspace
and vine were two of the biggest social
media outlets until they want myspace
loss of MySpace almost lost the entirety
of its user base and vine was shut down
due to a series of business decisions
that ignored these platforms respective
user bases leading to a transition to
new platforms which seemed more
conducive to content creators needs and
desires with this being 2018 the age of
YouTube as the world's only real video
sharing site is rapidly coming to a
close as alternatives like Vimeo
Facebook watch and Amazon continue to
rise in prominence furthermore if
YouTube's continuation of arbitrary D
monetization continues it may become a
necessity that I alongside other
channels begin the process of moving to
more crowdfunded sources of revenue like
patreon and abandon YouTube's existing
monetization system ie we take
monetization off our channels just D
monetize everything so I don't know I
mean that's just kind of my my my
statement on this um I mean I'd like to
believe it's well worded I'm a little
biased because I wrote it but still you
know I as much as I love YouTube I'm in
the Philip DeFranco for a Philip
DeFranco crowd I'm tired of defending a
platform that doesn't care enough to fix
its problems and so you know I I don't
know I mean you know maybe it's maybe
YouTube has just become complacent
because they have Google's money and
they're like look I mean you know we've
got Google money we're not going
anywhere but then what happens when
Google just gets rid of YouTube like
what would happen I mean Google has
YouTube because it's the biggest video
sharing platform in the world and sure
you know Google's search engine is tied
in with YouTube's search engine but I
mean you know Google's in the business
of making money that's really all it is
and I would like to believe that if
YouTube stopped you know basically
stopped being the biggest video sharing
platform Google would either buy the
next one that comes out or they would
just kind of cut in YouTube's loose but
the fact remains nothing's ever an
absolute you know nothing ever lasts
forever a time will come when YouTube
will start to struggle and it'll rely
it'll it'll need the help of its content
creators to stay afloat and if YouTube
content
path where YouTube starts seeking and
ask for a lifeline there's not gonna be
anybody there to give them one
but anyway without being said guys I'm
gonna bring this video to an end if
you're new here to comments explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like that we'll catch you all later
peace